j'ai passé ces sept dernières années
à vivre une vie de rêve
Bianca
Rocky mon père
j'ai tout construit grâce à eux
tu fais quoi là qu'est-ce que tu veux un
petit autographe dans tes rêves vas-y
dégage de ma caisse tu te rappelles pas
de moi
[Musique]
d'après combien 18 ans frère je suis
sorti à 8 jours
content de te revoir l'ami ouais je suis
parti un sacré bail mais je suis resté
en forme j'en ai encore sous le coude
viens me voir au club
c'est cool
[Musique]
c'est quoi votre histoire à tous les
deux il t'a rien dit on était comme des
frères
c'était moi le plus fort mais j'ai pas
eu l'occasion de le prouver la classe
côté cette ferme mais tu lui dois rien
donner arrête
Damien veut au monde entier il veut de
la casse je t'ai soutenu
passe la moitié de ta vie en trop là à
regarder quelqu'un vive ta vie
je veux tous ceux à quoi j'ai droit
c'est quoi une menace
je sais pas ce qui t'arrive
Damien était comme mon frère
[Musique]
on peut même plus parler faut peut-être
que ça se joue sur le ring
ce moment maintenant
[Musique]
il faut que tu arrêtes avec la peur
la culpabilité
arrête avec le passé et regarde le
présent
[Musique]